Voice-over: Good morning, Hank and John.
You remember that epic Batman argument you
had?
John (speaking): I kind of HATE Batman...
Voice-over: It just got songified so... now
we can all dance to the sound of brothers
fighting.
Hank (singing): You've got Batman ENTIRELY
wrong.
John, we are all bat-people.
(clap clap clap)
John (singing): Hank, Gotham never gets better
for long.
Crime is not actually caused by evil.
Hank (singing and overlapping John): We are
all bat-people!
John (singing): Crime is not actually caused
by evil!
(3 beat instrumental break)
John (singing): Batman's just a rich guy with
an affinity for bats, who is playing out his
insane fantasy...
how is that heroic?
Hank (singing): Batman's values and actions
are a reflection of our own values and actions
to make the world BETTER!
John (singing): Doesn't Batman understand
how difficult it is for an underfunded city
like Gotham to replace roads and bridges?
Hank (singing): We see ourselves in the cracks
in his facade, in his anger and frustration
because we have all these things too.
John (singing): Hank,
Hank (singing): John,
John (signing): Hank, Hank...
Hank (singing): John, you've got Batman ENTIRELY
wrong.....
John, we are all Bat-people!
( clap clap clap )
John (singing): Hank, Gotham never gets better
for long...
Crime is not actually caused by evil!
Hank (singing): We are all bat-people!
John (singing): Crime is not actually caused
by evil!
(Instrumental Break)
John (singing): Crime is caused by systemic
disenfranchisement and poverty and lack of
access to job opportunities...
Hank (singing): We are not the heroes Earth
needs (echos)... but the heroes Earth just
happened to get.
John (singing): Hank,
Hank (singing): John, John,
Hank (singing): John,
John (singing): Hank, Hank,
Hank (singing): John, you've got Batman ENTIRELY
wrong!
John, we are ALL Bat-people!
( clap clap, clap )
John (singing): Hank, Gotham never gets better
for long.
Crime is NOT actually caused by evil!
Hank (singing): We are all bat-people!
John (singing and slightly overlapping Hank):
Crime is not actually caused by evil...
(clap clap, clap clap)
Hank and John at the same time: John/Hank,
I will see you on Friday/Tuesday.
Voice-over: ...and everybody won.
THE END.
(voice-over clip from suggested video plays
over endroll)